bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de deux sujets qui me passionnent la
science et la musique vous le savez
l'évolution des styles musicaux a
toujours été fortement influencé par les
capacités et les sonorités des
instruments disponibles à une époque
donnée pour me prendre qu'un exemple on
peut penser à l'impact de l'invention du
piano sur le travail des compositeurs
qui ont suivi or au cours du 20e siècle
on a vu apparaître des instruments d'un
genre complètement nouveau qui ont
bouleversé une bonne partie de la
musique les synthétiseurs et aujourd'hui
on va parler du fonctionnement de ces
synthétiseurs et des principes
d'électronique et de traitement du
signal sur lesquels il se base c'est un
sujet qui me tient à cœur car toute ma
jeunesse mon père m'a biberonné à Pink
Floyd et mercenlaken Palmer Jean-Michel
Jarre Vangelis autant d'artistes qui ont
donné leur lettre de noblesse à ses
instruments révolutionnaires et comme il
est difficile d'évoquer les évolutions
techniques de ces instruments sans
parler de l'histoire de leur influence
musicale j'ai demandé à Marguerite de la
chaîne scarsando souvenir nous éclairer
là-dessus salut Marguerite est-ce que tu
peux nous dire un mot sur ta chaîne
salut David et merci pour l'invitation
sur ma chaîne je parle d'histoire de la
musique du Moyen-Âge à nos jours sans
faire de discrimination entre les
différentes époques ou les différents
styles je parle du chant grégorien comme
de l'hymne des États-Unis mais aussi du
Requiem de Brahms on me demandant
ensuite si Jul est un troubadour le but
c'est pas de dire qui est meilleur que
l'autre mais de lier les époques entre
elles en essayant au passage de
dépoussiérer ce qu'on appelle très
largement la musique classique et bien
sans plus attendre partons à la
découverte de ce qu'est un synthétiseur
[Musique]
pour parler du fonctionnement des
synthétiseurs il faut d'abord revenir à
ce qu'est le son vous le savez peut-être
les sons sont des ondes de pression qui
se manifestent surtout dans l'air qui
nous entoure l'air autour de nous
possède une certaine pression et il y a
plusieurs unités de mesure pour la
quantifier il y a le bas et l'air
ambiant est à environ un bar c'est
pratique ou bien encore le Pascal et un
bar vaut 100000 Pascal la pression de
l'air autour de nous n'est évidemment
pas parfaitement constante elle peut
varier d'un jour à l'autre d'un endroit
à l'autre comme on le voit parfois sur
les cartes météo mais elle va également
baisser si on se rend en altitude et sur
un total d'environ 100 000 les
variations de pression peuvent être de
plusieurs milliers de Pascal or le son
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est
également une variation de pression mais
sous la forme d'une oscillation très
faible mais très rapide on mesure la
fréquence d'un son en Hertz c'est à dire
en nombre d'oscillations par seconde et
pour les sons que l'oreille humaine peut
percevoir c'est typiquement entre 20 et
20 000 hertz plus la fréquence est
élevée plus le son est aigu
en revanche l'amplitude de l'oscillation
de pression est très faible une
oscillation de 1 Pascal d'amplitude dont
pas grand chose à priori ça correspond
déjà à un son de 94 décibels donc à peu
près le bruit d'une tondeuse à gazon il
y a quelque chose d'un peu étonnant à se
dire qu'on est sensible à des
oscillations de l'ordre d'une fraction
de Pascal sur un total de 100000 alors
que quand la pression ambiante change
lentement de plusieurs milliers de
Pascal et bien on s'en rend pas vraiment
compte on peut comparer ça à des vagues
sur l'océan si vous nagez qu'il y a 10
000 mètres d'eau en dessous de vous et
que ça change lentement vous ne vous en
rendez pas compte par contre une vague
de 1 m et bien vous allez la sentir
passer pour produire du son et donc pour
faire un instrument de musique il faut
d'une façon ou d'une autre produire des
oscillations de pression de l'air et il
y a pas de 36 solutions en fait il y en
a que deux
premièrement vous pouvez faire
osciller une pièce mécanique qui à son
tour va mettre en mouvement l'air autour
d'elle de façon périodique c'est ce qui
se passe avec la vibration d'une corde
ou bien quand on frappe sur un triangle
ou encore la peau d'une percussion la
deuxième solution c'est de faire
directement aussi les l'air dans une
cavité en exploitant des phénomènes de
résonance c'est ce qui permet par
exemple de produire du son avec une
flûte
ou encore en soufflant sur le goulot
d'une bouteille de bière évidemment
aujourd'hui on peut produire du son et
donc écouter de la musique sans avoir un
instrument qui joue directement à côté
de nous il suffit d'utiliser un
enregistrement pour faire un
enregistrement on place un micro qui
convertit les vibrations de l'air sous
forme d'un signal électrique et on peut
les restituer plus tard de façon
amplifiée avec un haut-parleur qui fait
l'inverse du micro il met en mouvement
une membrane en fonction du signal qu'il
reçoit mais malgré tout un haut-parleur
ça n'est pas un instrument de musique
quand on écoute un enregistrement bon le
son est plus ou moins bien restitué mais
à l'origine pour créer ce son et bien il
a fallu un vrai instrument et donc même
un son enregistré trouve forcément son
origine dans l'un des deux principes que
j'ai évoqués de l'air qui a été mis en
mouvement par une pièce mécanique ou par
un phénomène de résonance
mais au tout début du 20e siècle grâce à
la naissance de l'électronique on a vu
apparaître un instrument d'un genre
complètement nouveau échappant à cette
classification le thérémine
ce termine il va avoir une histoire
toute particulière très liée à son
créateur lève sergueil evic Sternen
qu'on connaît son nom de Léon terrine et
sa relation avec le régime communiste
qui se met en place en Russie termine
est un ingénieur qui est spécialisé
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale dans
les ondes radio puis au moment de la
révolution de 1917 il va rejoindre les
rangs des pôleschevy qu'en mettant en
place des réseaux de communication radio
pour eux et c'est un peu par hasard
qu'il va créer le thérémine en
travaillant sur un outil qui permettait
de mesurer la constante diététique des
gaz soit en fabriquant cet outil il va
remarquer qu'en passant sa main dans un
champ magnétique ça va produire un son
et là ça fait tilt parce que à côté de
tout ça termine est aussi musicien
jouant du violoncelle depuis son enfance
il semble qu'il voulait créer un
instrument qui est un son qui soit
satisfaisant dès sa première utilisation
contrairement violoncelle où les
premières années d'apprentissage sont
souvent assez pénibles à vivre pour les
oreilles des personnes vivant avec
l'élève instrumentiste avec cette
découverte hasardeuse sur son appareil
électromagnétique il se lance dans la
conception du thérémine entre 1918 et
1920 il va faire tout un tas de
prototypes et en 1922 c'est la
consécration pour lui puisque Lénine va
lui demander de lui présenter cette
instrument ce dernier va être
complètement conquis par cette invention
géniale qui va un peu lancer la volonté
des Russes de se montrer bien plus en
avance que leur voisin en termes
technologique ce terrible qui est le
tout premier instrument de musique
utilisant exclusivement l'électricité
pour fonctionner va devenir un outil de
propagande en 1927 terremen va être
envoyé partout dans le monde pour
montrer sa brillante invention et du
repassage à quel point le régime
communiste est merveilleux la tournée se
finit aux États-Unis mais au lieu d'y
rester quelques jours il va y rester
plus de 10 ans là-bas il dépose le
brevet pour son instrument le développe
étant de le commercialiser puis va de
plus en plus passer de temps dans la
haute société américaine ce qui n'est
pas sans intéresser le NKVD qui lui
aurait demandé de récolter quelques
petites informations bonnes à prendre en
gros termes serait devenu un espion pour
le compte de l'URSS jusqu'à ce qu'il
soit arrêté par le NKVD en 1938 et
envoyé dans un genre de goulag pour
scientifique dans lequel il était
contraint de créer des objets
technologiques pour le régime de Staline
et le thé Émile dans tout ça et bien il
se développe aux États-Unis parce que
les élèves américains de terremen dont
surtout Clara Rockmore vont continuer de
développer l'instrument et de le faire
découvrir aux gens
[Musique]
mais si elle aurait souhaité en faire un
instrument noble utilisé dans le
répertoire savant le thérémine n'aura
jamais de grands succès commercial et
restera une curiosité au son étrange qui
sera surtout utilisé dans les films de
science-fiction
[Musique]
mais finalement c'est dans la musique
pop que le thérémine trouvera ses
lettres de noblesse en étant
commercialisé par la marque moug donc
ton remplaera un peu plus tard
[Musique]
et aujourd'hui grâce à internet et
YouTube beaucoup de gens découvrent cet
instrument au son si particulier et
envoûtant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
essayons de comprendre les principes
électroniques du thérémine et notamment
comment il est possible d'en jouer sans
même toucher l'instrument alors
évidemment il y a un haut-parleur qui
permet de restituer le son par une
vibration de l'air afin qu'on l'entende
mais contrairement à tous les
instruments qu'on avait connus jusqu'ici
à la base de la naissance du son il n'y
a que des circuits électroniques la
création du son est purement synthétique
l'ingrédient de base c'est un
oscillateur il s'agit d'un module
électronique qui va délivrer un signal
électrique
oscillant qu'on va pouvoir amplifier et
envoyer dans le haut-parleur il existe
plusieurs façons de créer un oscillateur
avec des composants électroniques un des
principes les plus simples c'est celui
du feedback la rétroaction en bon
français on prend un composant
amplificateur et on le branche sur
lui-même c'est-à-dire qu'on connecte sa
sortie à son entrée on crée ainsi une
boucle de rétroaction mais on va
intercaler dans la boucle un filtre qui
va laisser passer seulement une seule
fréquence électrique
on injecte donc aucun signal au départ
et c'est juste le bruit électronique qui
va être amplifié filtré amplifié filtré
amplifié filtré etc et produire en
sortie un signal électrique oscillant à
la fréquence déterminée par le filtre
alors si on veut faire ça en pratique on
peut réaliser un montage en utilisant un
amplificateur opérationnel et pour le
filtre et bien on pourrait par exemple
choisir un filtre LC avec un
condensateur et une inductance alors
pour ceux qu'on fait l'électronique il
existe un lien entre la fréquence de
résonance du filtre et les valeurs de
capacité et d’inductance F = 1 sur 2 pi
racine de LC
donc un oscillateur c'est super il
suffit de choisir les composants comme
il faut et on peut obtenir un signal de
fréquence donnée mais en fait ça suffit
pas pour faire un terril mine si on a
qu'une seule fréquence donc une seule
hauteur de notes on va pas pouvoir jouer
à grand chose l'idée du thérémine c'est
de faire varier la fréquence du son
produit en faisant varier la capacité du
condensateur et donc la fréquence
sélectionnée par le filtre de
l'oscillateur
pour ça on va connecter une des plaques
du condensateur à cette grande pièce
métallique qu'on appelle une antenne or
il se trouve que la simple présence du
corps humain est notamment de la main à
proximité de l'antenne va légèrement
perturber la répartition des charges
électriques en surface et donc faire
varier la capacité du condensateur en
bougeant sa main on peut contrôler donc
la fréquence de l'oscillateur et la
hauteur de la note obtenue on a comme ça
un instrument de musique alors faudrait
aussi expliquer comment la deuxième
antenne contrôle le volume et je vous
passe quelques détails techniques sur
les circuits mais j'espère que vous
comprenez en quoi le thérémine était
révolutionnaire pour la première fois de
l'histoire on avait un instrument de
musique pour lequel la création du son
ne reposait pas sur la vibration d'une
pièce mécanique ou d'une masse d'air
mais sur une oscillation entièrement
synthétisée par des moyens électroniques
quelques années après le thérémine en
France va naître un instrument qui
fonctionne sur le même principe les
ondes Martenot inventées par Maurice
Martenot
[Musique]
là où c'est rigolo c'est que Maurice
martonneau tout comme thermen était un
violoncelliste qui pendant la Première
Guerre mondiale était opérateur radio
par contre on vous parlait du peu de
succès du thérémine dans la musique
savante parce qu'en fait ce sont les
ondes martonneaux qui vont prendre le
créneau en 1928 Maurice martonneau va
présenter son tout nouvel instrument au
public qui contrairement auréline à
l'avantage de présenter un aspect
familier il utilise un clavier de piano
peut-être que là est l'une des réponses
au fait que cet instrument ait eu plus
de succès que le thérémine on ne partait
pas sur des bases complètement nouvelles
en plus du clavier qui permet comme sur
un piano de jouer des intervalles de
demi-ton on trouve une bague que le
marterniste peut faire glisser sur un
ruban juste devant le clavier afin de
jouer un glissando parfait il n'y a plus
de ton ni de demi-ton ni même de quart
de ton tous les intervalles sont
possibles jusque dans les années 1980
cet instrument va être pas mal utilisé
et notamment musique savante pour moi
l'oeuvre la plus marquante c'est
sûrement la tour en Galilée la symphonie
de Olivier Messiaen parce que
indépendamment du fait qu'il y ait des
Ondes Martenot c'est une oeuvre
symphonique majeure du XXe siècle par
l'un des compositeurs majeurs du 20e
siècle
[Musique]
et retrouver les ondes martonneaux dans
ce type d'oeuvre n'a rien à nos dents
puisque ça les inscrit dans l'histoire
de la musique comme un instrument qui
n'est pas juste une curiosité
technologique mais un instrument qui a
su trouver sa place dans le répertoire
en plus lors de la première
représentation de cette œuvre c'est
Ginette martonneau sort de l'inventeur
de l'instrument qui interprété la
partition pour les ondes ce qui je
trouve ajoute à la saveur de cet œuvre
en revanche cet instrument sera un peu
oublié au fil des années l'arrivée
d'autres instruments électroniques plus
polyvalents va considérablement diminuer
la trait musicale des ondes martonneaux
même si dans les années 2000 certains
musiciens vont s'en emparer pour un peu
les réhabiliter à l'image du guitariste
de Radiohead Johnny Greenwood qui dira
des ondes qui lui permettent de chanter
et alors qu'il ne sait pas le faire avec
sa voix
[Musique]
évidemment vous l'avez peut-être senti
la limitation des instruments comme le
terrine et les ondes Martenot c'est que
si on utilise juste un simple
oscillateur tel que celui que j'ai
décrit on obtient uniquement un son très
pur ce qui peut être un peu limitant du
point de vue créatif les instruments
usuels n'ont jamais un son parfaitement
pur et c'est d'ailleurs en partie ce qui
les distingue et fait leur intérêt pour
s'en rendre compte on peut enregistrer
différents instruments jouant une même
note et analyser les fréquences
contenues dans le son
[Musique]
pour faire cette analyse on va tracer le
spectre de chaque signal sonore en
mathématiquement ça se fait en calculant
la transformée de Fourier et ça permet
d'obtenir la décomposition comme une
somme de sinusoïde de fréquence donnée
alors ici j'utilise le logiciel Audacity
et son analyseur de spectre mais vous
pouvez aussi le faire de façon très
simple avec l'application physique dont
j'avais parlé dans une vidéo pour la
main à la pâte ici on a joué un la avec
un diapason parfait ça correspondrait à
un pic à 440 Hertz et vous voyez avec
les différents instruments que bien que
la note jouée soit la même le contenu en
fréquence de ces instruments est
différent à part la fréquence
fondamentale les spectres contiennent
d'autres fréquences on appelle ça des
partiels et notamment des fréquences qui
sont des multiples entiers de la
fréquence fondamentale deux fois trois
fois quatre fois cinq fois etc
ces fréquences multiples se sont les
harmoniques et le contenu en harmonie
que l'on obtient avec un instrument va
déterminer son timbre c'est ce qui
caractérise en partie cette instrument
et permet de le différencier d'un autre
le timbre d'un piano n'est pas celui
d'une flûte ou d'une guitare même quand
il joue exactement la même note si on
veut fabriquer d'autres instruments
électroniques avec des timbres nouveau
et bien à eux et bien il faut qu'on
trouve un moyen de jouer sur le contenu
en harmonique des sons que l'on va
synthétiser alors a priori il y a une
solution facile pour modifier le timbre
d'un instrument synthétique on a vu
qu'un oscillateur simple nous donne un
signal sinusoïdal à une certaine
fréquence si on veut fabriquer un timbre
plus riche on n'a qu'à ajouter d'autres
oscillateurs qui sont réglés sur les
fréquences des harmoniques alors ça
fonctionne effectivement et on appelle
ça de la synthèse additive mais il
existe d'autres façons de faire et
notamment le principe opposé la synthèse
soustractive l'idée est simple on va
partir d'un son contenant au contraire
une très grande quantité d'harmonique et
on va
le son en filtrant certaines fréquences
la synthèse soustractive et la forme de
synthèse la plus utilisée aujourd'hui et
c'est donc surtout de ça dont on va
parler maintenant pour faire ce travail
de sculpture du son avec des
synthétiseurs les musiciens utilisent
différents modules électroniques qu'ils
vont connecter on parle de synthèse
modulaire
alors comme moi je n'ai pas de vrais
synthé modulaire je vais utiliser un
logiciel open source qui s'appelle VCV
rack et qui permet d'émuler les
différents modules qui composent un vrai
synthétiseur analogique et on peut les
placer sur un rad virtuel et les
connecter en fait
comme point de départ de la synthèse
soustractive on l'a dit il nous faut un
son qui contiennent déjà beaucoup
d'harmonique notre bloc brut qu'on va
sculpter et l'oscillateur simple que
j'ai décrit ça ne marche pas puisqu'il
nous donne essentiellement qu'une
fréquence il nous faut un autre type de
d'oscillateur en utilisant des schémas
électroniques différents on peut créer
des oscillateurs qui fournissent des
signaux électriques qui ne seront pas
sinusoïdaux mais par exemple
triangulaire carré ou encore en dents de
scie alors voyons les sons que ça
produit ici je vais prendre un module
oscillateur que je vais connecter au
module de la sortie son
voilà pour l'instant on obtient un son
très simple
et pour pouvoir visualiser le signal je
vais faire la même chose mais en
intercalant un oscilloscope ainsi qu'un
analyseur de spectre alors il est un peu
moins précis que celui de dacity mais
bon ça va le faire donc ici aussi la
terre est réglé à 261 Hertz c'est le dos
du milieu sur un piano ou une partition
et je suis sur la sortie sinusoïdale de
l'oscillateur on voit sur l'oscillo
qu'effectivement la courbe est
sensiblement sinusoïdale et le spectre
nous montre bien la fondamentale à 261
Hertz mais on voit aussi quelques
harmoniques supplémentaires alors pas
très intense vous voyez c'est plusieurs
dizaines de décibels sous la
fondamentale ça veut dire que notre
signal n'est pas parfaitement sinusoïdal
alors maintenant on va passer au signal
triangulaire
on en a déjà un son un peu plus riche
avec un peu plus de rugosité alors
l'oscillo nous montre que l'oscillateur
n'est pas parfait c'est pas un triangle
pur mais enfin très très grave et si on
analyse le spectre obtenu et bien on
voit qu'on a plus essentiellement une
fréquence pure mais un certain nombre
d'harmonie la première elle est un peu
en dessous de 800 Hertz c'est 3 fois la
fondamentale et ça correspond à un sol à
la quinte du dos celle d'après c'est 5
fois la fondamentale un peu au dessus de
1300 c'est un mi la tierce majeure du
dos alors ce sont uniquement les
harmoniques impaires là on n'a pas le
double ou le quadruple la fondamental
alors maintenant passons au signal carré
[Musique]
la même topo le signal est pas
parfaitement carré
et on retrouve les harmoniques impaires
mais à un niveau plus fort qu'avec le
triangle vous voyez le son est plus
riche plus texturé
d'ailleurs peut-être que cette sonorité
vous rappelle quelque chose c'est
exactement celle de la musique des
premiers jeux vidéo il y a une raison
pour ça c'est qu'un signal carré d'un
point de vue informatique c'est super
facile à coder parce que l'information
est binaire donc quand on n'a pas une
machine très puissante faire de la
musique en signal carré c'est assez
économique et c'est ce qui fait qu'en
fait dans notre imaginaire le timbre
d'un oscillateur signal carré est très
associé au premier jeu vidéo
[Musique]
bon et voyons enfin le signal en dents
de scie c'est le plus riche vous voyez
on a un son très rugueux avec beaucoup
d'harmoniques à des niveaux plus élevés
et comme on voit là sur le spectre et
cette fois notamment on a les
harmoniques paires par exemple deux fois
ou quatre fois la fondamentale qui sont
les octaves supérieures de notre dos de
départ
[Musique]
pour créer notre matériau de base on
peut donc utiliser ces quatre familles
d'oscillateurs qui fournissent beaucoup
d'harmoniques on peut notamment en
superposer plusieurs et on peut même
ajouter des sons très riches comme des
bruits blancs ou des bruits roses qui
contiennent plus ou moins toutes les
fréquences électroniquement pour faire
ces oscillateurs on l'a dit on a besoin
de composants amplificateurs au début du
20e siècle on utilisait des tubes à vide
ces grosses lampes qu'on retrouve
parfois dans certains amplis de guitares
par exemple l'inconvénient c'est qu'il
en faut beaucoup et que ça prend de la
place les premiers synthétiseurs avaient
ainsi des tailles absolument prohibitive
comme par exemple le légendaire RCA
marktou installé à l'université de
Colombia en 1957 et qui occupait toute
une pièce et c'est ce qui dans les
années 60 motiva l'ingénieur Robert mug
a essayé de miniaturiser tout ça en
utilisant plutôt des transistors à la
place des tubes à vides ces transistors
à semi-conducteur venaient tout juste
être inventés et ils étaient bien plus
petits que les tubes MOOC commence à
ainsi à créer les premiers synthétiseurs
portables ou du moins transportable
comme on vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est une marque qui va d'abord
commercialiser des thérémines et oui on
y revient toujours d'ailleurs si vous
cherchez à vous procurer un terril-mal
aujourd'hui vous achèterez très
probablement un boulet mais
contrairement à l'arrivée du terrine et
même des ondes martenots va vraiment
laisser son empreinte dans l'histoire de
la musique va vraiment créer une
révolution et dépasser le stade de
curiosité technologique musicale l'un
des problèmes des deux premières
instruments c'est sûrement qu'ils sont
arrivés trop tôt dans le monde de la
musique dans la période
d'entre-deux-guerres les compositeurs
classiques les plus actifs sont sûrement
ravés les progrès pas le genre à mettre
des instruments électroniques dans leur
musique et côté musique populaire le
jazz étant plein boom mais la seule
utilisation de l'électronique est pour
amplifier le son d'instruments
acoustique comme la guitare ou la voix
puis arrive la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et ça nécessitait de créer le monde
d'après qui celui-là a existé pour le
coup
musicalement compositeur et interprète
vont vouloir repartir de zéro et
déconstruire ce qu'il se faisait déjà
les synthétiseurs de moug vont avoir un
grand rôle là-dedans le premier
synthétiseur modulaire mood doit sa
naissance à la rencontre entre Robert
smog et heart touch les deux hommes se
sont rencontrés car Deutsch compositeur
expérimental cherchait de nouvelles
façons de créer du son il a donc demandé
un moug qui fabriquait alors ces termes
s'ils pouvaient l'idée ils se sont mis à
travailler à bidouiller et à imaginer et
à créer le premier synthétiseur
modulaire Mog mais en 1965 au début cet
instrument aux aires de machines
d'opératrice téléphonique va rester dans
un cercle d'expérimentateur et
d'improvisateur assez fermé avant que le
départ Wendy Carlos
en 1968 elle sort switch and back un
album de pièces de Bach jouer uniquement
au synthétiseur modulaire de mug
et figurez-vous que cet album a
rencontré un très grand succès ceux-ci
dans le top 10 des ventes américaines
atteignant le million de ventes en 1974
et remportant même trois Gremy wards
c'est un succès retentissant tampon
interprète que l'instrument moug et
forcément ce sont des parties s'ouvrent
pour Carlos ce sera notamment
l'interprétation de BO de film comme
Orange mécanique dans laquelle elle joue
toujours sur son moug des pièces de
Beethoven et Purcell
[Applaudissements]
ou même la composition de la BO du film
Tron révolutionnaire lui aussi en termes
numériques
[Musique]
pour Mau que ce sera la consécration et
la participation à l'autre révolution
musicale les postes de radio et les
tourne-disque c'est démocratise et entre
dans les foyers des gens normaux ce
n'est plus un luxe de pouvoir écouter la
musique chez soi et ce n'est plus si
difficile d'enregistrer un album les
jeunes prennent plus de place dans la
société alors leur musique aussi et le
résultat de tout ça c'est que la musique
populaire prend de plus en plus de place
dans le paysage musical occidental on
veut du nouveau on veut du frais et quoi
de plus nouveau que la musique
électronique alors après cet album de
Wendy Carlos plein de musiciens
populaires vont vouloir s'emparer des
synthés et qui de plus populaires à la
fin des années 60 que les Beatles si
vous écoutez bien l'album Abbey Road
vous pourrez entendre un de ces
synthétiseurs sur plusieurs morceaux il
existe même un album de George Harrison
vous suffit je joue sur un dessin Tod
modulaire de moug mais bon franchement
c'est d'un intérêt musical assez limité
l'un des plus célèbres utilisateurs de
ces santé c'est sûrement qui s'émerson
membre du groupe Emerson Laken Palmer au
début des années 70 ils s'empare de
l'instrument il va faire du synthé un
instrument cool au même titre que la
guitare électrique et ses guitares qui
gesticulent dans tous les sens
provoquant la liesse des femmes le
clavier risque devient une rockstar à
part entière
[Musique]
par contre remerson deviendra aussi la
hantise de tous les redis ce qu'il
croise vous l'avez peut-être remarqué
mais cet instrument est particulièrement
volumineux celui des personnes pesait
plus de 250 kilos et faisait plus de 3
mètres de haut alors il l'emmènera pas
partout mais il est présent à beaucoup
des concerts du groupe d'ailleurs ce
sera bien le seul à le faire et c'est
quelque chose à laquelle va se heurter
moug c'est si on électronique sont
révolutionnaires sont nouveaux plaisent
aux musiciens au public mais les
machines sont énormes et compliquées
alors en 1970 MOOC décide de créer un
concentré de ces synthétiseurs
modulaires et va lancer le minimum qui
lui est un synthétiseur analogue toute
la technologie move regroupée dans un
seul petit instrument aux possibilités
quinzie infinies en termes de création
de son bien plus simple d'utilisation
c'est tout premier synthétiseur qu'on
pourrait qualifier populaire et qui va
traverser les époques on le retrouve
chez Pink Floyd Toto Jean-Michel Jarre
Daft Punk Herby Hancock ABA et aussi
dans le groupe allemand Kraftwerk qui
est l'un des pionniers de la musique
électronique dans les années 70 la
musique d'aujourd'hui serait sûrement
bien différente si MOOC n'avait pas
bidouillé en compagnie du compositeur
Deutsch à la recherche de son nouveau
mais comment fait-on pour créer les sons
si riches qu'on a entendu dans tous ces
morceaux on a vu grâce aux oscillateurs
comment générer des sons contenant
beaucoup d'harmoniques mais ça ne suffit
pas l'étape suivante pour sculpter notre
son c'est de réaliser de la synthèse
soustractive en supprimant certaines
fréquences et on en privilégiant
d'autres pour ça on va utiliser un
filtre qui va modifier l'intensité
associée à chaque fréquence pour
visualiser l'effet d'un filtre sur le
son il suffit de représenter son
atténuation en fonction de la fréquence
un filtre très classique c'est ce qu'on
appelle un filtre passe-bas on choisit
une fréquence qu'on va appeler la
fréquence de coupure disons 1000 Hertz
en dessous de cette valeur le filtre
n'atténue pas donc une atténuation de 0
décibel et au-delà de 1000 Hertz
l'atténuation est de plus en plus
importante donc on a une pente plus la
pente est forte plus la coupure sera
nette
pour intégrer ça dans notre son on va
utiliser un module qui réalise ce genre
de filtre ou du moins une forme
approchée dans un premier temps on va
essayer de visualiser l'effet du filtre
grâce à l'analyseur de spectre
alors pour ça je vais utiliser un bruit
blanc que je vais envoyer dans
l'analyseur de spectre le principe d'un
bruit blanc c'est de posséder une
répartition homogène sur toutes les
fréquences on voit ici qu'on a un
spectre essentiellement plein et ensuite
je fais passer le signal dans le module
de filtre
et dans un autre analyseur de spectre
pour pouvoir visualiser l'effet sur le
signal après filtrage et là vous voyez
que les fréquences basses sont
préservées et que les fréquences hautes
sont atténuées avec une sorte de pente
alors la fréquence de coupure du filtre
ici elle est autour de 2 kHz mais si je
fais varier cette fréquence et bien on
peut visualiser l'impact sur la forme du
filtre
je monte la fréquence de coupure et je
la descends
voilà bon ça c'était juste pour
visualiser on a même pas mis sur la
sortie son le son ne serait pas très
agréable
et maintenant un serrons ce genre de
filtre dans notre chaîne alors on va
prendre un signal en dents de scie
histoire de partir de quelque chose de
bien riche puis on va filtrer
et écouter
et on trace le spectre avant et après et
en fait on voit clairement l'effet du
filtre sur les harmoniques vous pouvez
entendre le résultat d'ailleurs quand je
fais varier la fréquence de coupure
et plus la fréquence de coupure est
basse plus on étouffe les hautes
fréquences
[Musique]
alors ici évidemment je le fais avec une
simulation sur VCV avec un vrai synthé
analogique les deux paramètres du filtre
la fréquence de coupure et puis la pente
vont dépendre des composants
électroniques qu'on a mis dans le module
et ça va permettre de jouer sur le
timbre qu'on obtient le contenu en
harmonique du signal alors ici on l'a
dit le filtre est passe-bas il laisse
passer les basses fréquences mais aussi
on peut avoir un filtre passe haut par
exemple qui fait l'inverse ou deux types
de filtres plus sophistiqués mais une
chose qu'on peut faire avec donne pas
mal de signatures au son c'est de faire
l'inverse d'un filtrage c'est à dire de
booster certaines plages de fréquence le
truc classique c'est de le faire juste
autour de la fréquence de coupure
si je vais reprendre mon filtre
passe-bas et ajouter ce qu'on appelle
une résonance qui va créer un pic
vous voyez ici autour de la fréquence de
coupure
et ça va voir comme effet de privilégier
les fréquences situées juste autour de
la coupure donc ici deux kilowatts et
vous voyez la forme du filtre sur le
bruit blanc
et sur le son voici l'effet de la
résonance on peut en mettre plus ou
moins
et on peut jouer comme ça avec la
résonance et puis la fréquence de
coupure
jusqu'à avoir un timbre que l'on trouve
intéressant
bien alors tout ça est très sympathique
et ça donne déjà énormément de
possibilités en combinant plusieurs
oscillateurs en variant les formes
d'ondes et en jouant avec un ou
plusieurs filtres et leurs paramètres
mais pour l'instant notre son est quand
même très statique il y a aucune
variation dans le temps en chose qu'on
peut faire c'est de faire varier
légèrement la fréquence de l'oscillateur
donc ici je vais toucher le bouton de
fréquence
monter et descendre
c'est sympa ça fait une sorte de vibrato
sur le son mais c'est un peu fastidieux
à faire à la main
donc on va automatiser tout ça
la première chose à savoir c'est qu'un
oscillateur de ce type s'appelle en fait
un VCO pour voltage contour le silater
c'est à dire que je peux piloter sa
fréquence en lui envoyant un signal à
une certaine tension
tout à l'heure dans le cas du thérémie
nous faisait varier la fréquence en
changeant la capacité d'un condensateur
et bien là c'est une variation de
tension qui peut provoquer un changement
de fréquence de l'oscillateur
alors allons-y avec ce module je vais
envoyer une tension fixe pour piloter la
fréquence de l'oscillateur
on peut lire la tension appliquée ici
c'est zéro volt et en fait c'est une
convention entre 0 volts ça correspond
au dos du milieu donc 261 Hertz et
ensuite la fréquence va varier selon la
règle un Volt par Octave donc regardez
si je monte progressivement la tension
de pilotage
la fréquence augmente
[Musique]
et voilà un vol à peu près je retombe
sur un dos mais une octave au dessus
donc autour de 520 Hertz et donc avec ce
principe d'oscillateur commandant en
tension je peux donc piloter la
fréquence à partir d'un signal
électrique et si je veux créer un effet
de trémolo donc une fréquence qui aussi
légèrement et bien il suffit que la
tension qui pilote soit elle-même aussi
lente alors là faut faire une petite
pause j'ai un oscillateur à une certaine
fréquence et je veux faire aussi les la
fréquence donc piloter l'oscillateur
avec un deuxième oscillateur il faut
réaliser qu'il est différent du premier
notre premier oscillateur est réglé à
une fréquence relativement élevée c'est
quelques centaines ou quelques milliers
de Hertz suivant la note qu'on cherche
alors que les variations que je
réalisais à la main en tournant le
bouton c'était bison quelques Hertz
c'était quelques changements par seconde
donc pour automatiser ce mouvement on
veut utiliser un oscillateur dit basse
fréquences qui aussi là quelques Hertz
en anglais c'est LFO pour l'eau floconcy
aussi later alors voilà ici on a un
module LFO dont on peut régler la
fréquence et on va injecter un peu de ce
signal au silent dans la tension qui
pilote l'oscillateur qui produit le son
et voilà le genre de choses qu'on peut
obtenir en dosant les oscillations vous
voyez l'impact sur le son sur le signal
aussi l'eau et sur le spectre la
fréquence de l'oscillateur sonore bouge
légèrement créant un effet de vibrato et
je peux m'amuser à ajuster sa vitesse en
jouant sur le FFO
[Musique]
ça c'est donc pour un effet de vibrato
une oscillation de la hauteur de la note
dans le même genre on peut utiliser un
LFO pour contrôler non pas la fréquence
du son mais son intensité et donc faire
ce qu'on appelle un très molo
alors pour faire varier l'intensité du
son en fonction d'une tension appliquée
on a besoin d'un module qu'on appelle
voltage control amplifire VCA et le VCA
va moduler le volume sonore en fonction
d'une tension de pilotage qu'il reçoit
ici
donc ici on fait passer notre signal
dans le VCA pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de tension de pilotage donc ça passe
entièrement
et quand on le connecte avec
l'oscillateur basse fréquence
voilà ce qu'on obtient la fréquence du
son reste constante la hauteur de la
note change pas mais le volume aussi on
a un effet de très mollo
et on peut ajuster la vitesse du trémolo
avec la fréquence du LFO
et à partir de là il y a plein de choses
qui sont possibles parce que beaucoup
des paramètres dont on a parlé dans les
différents modules sont eux aussi
contrôlables en tension on peut donc par
exemple contrôler la résonance du filtre
ou bien le cutoff
[Musique]
et puis aussi bien sûr changer la forme
du signal éléphant
et donc rien qu'avec ces quelques
modules
le nombre de possibilités de connexion
est déjà énorme on peut laisser libre
cours à sa créativité pour sculpter le
son de son choix
bon alors là vous allez me dire c'est
cool mais on a toujours pas vraiment de
notes pas de mélodie il y a même pas de
clavier dans ce montage et bien
figurez-vous que ça n'empêche pas de
créer de la musique avec effectivement
point besoin de son qu'on comprenne un
clavier et pour ça je vous invite à
découvrir elianradig et son ARP 2500
Radic apprend la musique de manière
assez classique jouant du piano et de la
harpe sans un très grand talent mais en
étudiant énormément la théorie musicale
à ces 19 ans elle déménage de Paris pour
Nice et s'installe proche de l'aéroport
elle adorait les sons que produisaient
les avions au décollage et à
l'atterrissage selon well en
sélectionnant les sons il était possible
de se créer une petite symphonie
intérieure c'est une idée qui va lui
rester en tête jusqu'au jour où à la
radio elle entend une pièce de Pierre
Schaeffer
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour elle une révélation tout
peut devenir musique Shafer est un
pionnier de ce qu'on appelle la musique
concrète une branche de la musique
expérimentale dans laquelle on considère
qu'on peut faire de la musique avec tout
son qui nous entoure à partir du moment
où on considère que la musique c'est du
son agencé dans le temps par un humain
radis rencontre Scheffer en 1950 et
devient son élève elle fera partie des
pionniers de la musique concrète sans
jamais en avoir le crédit du fait de son
genre puis bon au fil des années elle va
un peu se détacher d'idée de Scheffer
qui est d'agencer des sons pour faire de
la musique corradig pense que la musique
est déjà présente dans les sons alors en
1970 elle part pour New York où on lui
apporte bien plus de reconnaissance
qu'en France et où elle découvre la RP
2500 un synthétiseur qui deviendra son
compagnon de composition pendant les 30
années suivantes la RP 2500 est parfait
pour radiguer il lui permet de produire
la musique qu'elle souhaite et elle
n'est plus limitée la particularité de
cette collaboration entre la
compositrice et sa machine c'est qu'elle
n'utilisait pas de clavier
elle se fait créatrice de son avec son
nouvel instrument et mène l'oreille des
auditeurs vers une nouvelle découverte
sonore à chaque seconde de son œuvre il
n'est pas question de consonance ou
dissonance les mêmes pas question de
rythme note c'est compositions sont des
défilements et des assemblages de son
créé sur la RP 2500 sur des durées très
longues
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle le drone un genre
de musique minimaliste dans lequel on
fait usage de son ou d'accord très longs
qui changent très peu et très lentement
dans le milieu des années 70 elle va se
convertir au bouddhisme et cette
nouvelle spiritualité va avoir un impact
certain sur sa musique elle admirait le
fait que Bouddha soit un humain et non
un Dieu qui est réussi à trouver le
plein état d'éveil et elle va s'inspirer
de ça pour ses compositions son
chef-d'oeuvre composé en trois parties
entre 85 et 93 trilogie de la mort
s'inspire directement du bouddhisme
puisqu'il est son adaptation musicale du
Livre des Morts tibétains il va au fil
de sa création se révéler comme une
introspection de radis elle-même qui vit
lors de la composition de la deuxième
partie de son œuvre l'épreuve la plus
terrible qu'on puisse imaginer la mort
d'un de ses enfants toute l'œuvre peut
sonner comme une méditation qui se
transforme en réflexion intérieure du
deuil de la compositrice pour finir en
une sorte de lâcher prise comme si
toutes les émotions vécues pleinement
pendant la durée de l'oeuvre exploser et
s'envoler trilogie de la mort dure
certes près de trois heures
c'est une expérience à vivre une
expérience à ressentir dans laquelle le
temps est complètement distendu c'est
une imbrication de son créé sur une
machine mais qui prouve bien que la
musique n'a pas à être composée de
rythme ou de notes pour exister bon
malgré tout tout le monde n'est pas
Eliane Radigue à pouvoir créer de la
musique même sans note alors allons-y
cette fois on va brancher un clavier sur
nos modules alors un très compliqué moi
je vais juste brancher un clavier midi
sur mon ordinateur sur un synthé
analogique puisqu'on contrôle les
oscillateurs en tension il suffit de
s'assurer que chaque touche du clavier
envoie une tension différente à
l'oscillateur et puis si on règle bien
tout ça on obtient les notes de la gamme
alors une petite subtilité tout de même
sur les vrais synthés analogiques les
composants électroniques notamment les
oscillateurs ont des caractéristiques
qui peuvent varier légèrement avec la
température et donc en fonction de la
chauffe du synthé ou de la température
ambiante faut parfois faire un peu
attention pour s'assurer d'être bien
accordé donc là j'ai ajouté un module
pour lire l'entrée du clavier et
simplement piloter l'oscillateur et
l'ampli en fonction de la touche que je
presse
alors c'est bien je joue c'est top
je peux créer de la musique avec un son
sympathique mais vous noterez quand même
une petite faiblesse le son n'a pas
franchement de dynamique quand j'appuie
sur une touche ça part tout de suite et
quand je relâche ça s'arrête tout de
suite en pratique les vraies instruments
ont des dynamiques de son qui sont plus
riches que ça qui leur sont propres sur
un piano on va avoir une attaque un peu
percussive puis le son va s'atténuer
progressivement et ben on peut essayer
de recréer ce genre de choses avec un
synthétiseur et pour ça il va falloir
jouer sur l'enveloppe du son c'est à
dire son évolution au cours du temps à
partir du moment où on va attaquer la
note on a déjà vu qu'on pouvait faire
varier l'enveloppe d'un signal grâce à
l'amplificateur contrôlé en tension le
VCA et on avait branché un LFO dessus
pour créer un effet de trémolo mais en
fait en envoyant un signal de la forme
qu'on souhaite et ben on peut créer la
dynamique qu'on veut alors on pourrait
imaginer les choses complètement tordues
mais en pratique on retrouve toujours
les mêmes ingrédients
donc on va paramétrer une courbe
d'enveloppe avec ce qu'on appelle un
ADSR pour attaque dicket ce stay release
la courbe A en gros la forme suivante le
signal augmentent rapidement jusqu'à un
pic puis redescend jusqu'à un plateau
intermédiaire et là il faut s'imaginer
que ce plateau va durer autant que l'on
tient la touche et quand on lâche la
touche il redescend jusqu'à 0 et ce sont
ces quatre phases voilà qu'on appelle
ADSR et chacune est réglable avec un
paramètre et en connectant le module
ADSR au pilotage de l'amplification ou
VCA on peut créer la dynamic souhaitée
pour l'enveloppe du son
alors l'attaque c'est le temps
nécessaire au signal pour atteindre son
pic d'intensité donc voici une attaque
courte
et voici un exemple d'attaque longue
ensuite dicket c'est la vitesse à
laquelle le signal descend suite à
l'attaque
ce stand c'est le niveau auquel le
signal sera maintenu tant qu'on ne
relâche pas la touche et release c'est
le temps du retour à zéro
et en release long par exemple
signifiera que le son se poursuivra même
une fois qu'on a relâché la touche
et comme toujours avec les principes de
la synthèse modulaire en fait la DSR
c'est un module de plus on peut s'amuser
à le connecter de façon complètement
libre à tous les autres si ça nous
chante on peut par exemple contrôler la
fréquence de coupure du filtre avec un
ADSR et donc là j'ai fait un mélange de
un peu tout ce qu'on a vu on a un ADSR
sur l'enveloppe un autre sur la
fréquence de coupure du filtre et puis
on a un LFO qui pilote la résonance
et là je commence à avoir un son
sympathique
[Musique]
il existe encore bien d'autres types de
modules permettant de séquencer les
notes de réaliser des filtres complexes
comme les formants qui mettent le son
des voyelles etc et bien sûr chaque
synthétiseur possède ses modules propres
qui font sa caractéristique sonore voici
donc pour les principes de base de la
synthèse soustractive alors je
l'évoquais au début il existe d'autres
formes de synthèse une qui est
particulièrement appréciée pour sa
richesse c'est la synthèse FM en
modulation de fréquence et la sortez les
coupes mulet on arrive dans les années
80 1983 marquera l'arrivée d'un
mastodonte du monde des synthétiseurs le
Yamaha DX7 en fait c'est simple à sa
sortie Yamaha espérait en vendre 20 000
la première année ils en vendront en
fait 150000 à titre de comparaison en
disant le mini Mog s'est vendu à 12000
exemplaires si vous écoutez un son des
années 80 avec un synthé c'est
probablement le DX7 cet instrument va
avoir tellement de succès que beaucoup
de concurrents diamaha vont faire
faillite ou devoir faire des plans de
relance économique assez poussés parce
que les ingénieurs de chez Yamaha ont
été très malins la synthèse FM existe
déjà depuis 1973 inventé par John
showing professeur de l'université de
Stanford sauf que personne ne s'y
intéresse vraiment c'est un procédé très
coûteux à mettre en place mais Yamaha va
miser dessus va faire travailler ses
ingénieurs et surtout va déposer des
brevets qui lui permettent de garder
l'exclusivité de ses avancées pendant 10
ans d'où la panique qui est la chute
chez la concurrence qui continue de
produire des synthétiseurs analogiques
au son bien moins tranchants avec
clinquants que les DX7 grâce au DX7 on a
l'instrument dont le fonctionnement est
bien plus simple que les gros
synthétiseurs modulaires puisqu'il
suffit d'appuyer sur des boutons pour
obtenir tout un tas de son programme et
de grande qualité ceci dit créer des
sons avec est possible mais plutôt
compliqué il est assez robuste pour être
trimballé partout en tournée et il n'a
pas de dimension extrême comme les
premiers mots Go la RP 2500 il a un prix
assez attractif c'est un instrument qui
est facile de se procurer facile à
transporter facile à prendre en main
pour peu qu'on ne cherche pas à aller
plus loin que les sons déjà proposés par
la machine
en clair tout l'inverse des premiers
synthétiseurs et surtout son son est
nouveau qui se démarque des sons
analogues et trouvent sa place dans
l'esthétique des années 80 enfin même
allons plus loin il sera l'une des
origines de l'esthétique sonore bien
plus explosive des années 80 pas
étonnant donc de le retrouver chez Queen
aha Stevie Wonder Toto Madonna Europe
Jean-Jacques Goldman Dépêche Mode
U2 craftwerk Jean-Michel Jarre Elton
John Daniel Balavoine Supertramp Michael
Jackson David Bowie
star des années 80 il y a sûrement des X
pas loin alors on aurait pu rester des
heures à vous parler de tous les
morceaux mythiques composés sur ces
différents instruments mais la vidéo est
déjà bien assez longue et encore je me
suis retenu de vous brancher sur la BO
des Mystérieuses Cités d'Or qui est
quand même le must en la matière
aujourd'hui tous ces synthé vintage dont
on a parlé sont très difficiles à
trouver et le plus souvent hors de prix
heureusement on sait maintenant émuler
de façon numérique la plupart des
circuits électroniques qui étaient
utilisés et même les fabricants
historiques de synthé s'y mettent et
proposent des logiciels qui reproduisent
à merveille ces historique voilà si le
sujet vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
expérimenter vous même par exemple avec
VC verac donc j'ai parlé et qui est en
open source merci à Grégoire blanc un
musicien français qui est un des rares
instrumentistes à jouer du thérémine et
qui nous a gentiment prêté ses images
allez voir son travail sur sa chaîne
Youtube et puis surtout merci infiniment
à Marguerite pour son regard historique
ou musical j'ai appris plein de trucs
j'espère que vous aussi n'hésitez pas à
aller voir sa chaîne scarsando je vous
mets évidemment le lien en description
voilà abonnez-vous à toutes ces chaînes
les cloches les pousses tout ça et puis
moi je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
nouvelle vidéo